mahesh kumar was supposed to start
preparing his fields for planting rice
three weeks ago but this is the first
day that the water supply has come
after weeks of power cuts resulting in a
lack of water mahesh doesn't know how
long today's supply will last
we have to till the field add manure use
the tractor and for all this we need
regular water supply from the time it's
sown to its harvest if there is
irregular supply either the quality of
rice will deteriorate or the plant will
die the farmer will suffer if any of
this happens
homes and businesses have also been
suffering power cuts for weeks this
hospital in uttar pradesh has been
without electricity for at least six
hours a day forcing staff to use diesel
generators when the price of the fuel is
at a record high
we are spending more than 150 dollars
every day on diesel we're not passing
the burden onto the patients right now
but if these power outages continue
we'll be forced to increase patients
fees
the cuts are due to a severe shortage of
coal at power stations
experts blame the huge demand for
electricity during a heat wave coupled
with bottlenecks and transportation and
sky rocketing prices of imported coal
with climate change exacerbating heat
waves environmentalists say the answer
to meet rising electricity needs isn't
to open more coal mines as india is
doing because that will increase
greenhouse gases that trap more heat
seventy percent of india's electricity
comes from coal-fired power stations
analysts say the latest crisis is a
reminder to invest more in green energy
when i say renewable energy the whole
ecosystem needs to be developed because
renewable energy is intermittent source
of power again we rely on imported uh
modules and cells for you know building
up solar capacity or when capacity in
india so we need to build across the
value chain
the international atomic energy agency
says demand for electricity in india is
expected to increase more than anywhere
else in the world over the next 20 years
as the country develops
as mahesh uses the scarce water to clean
himself and cool off
he says his livelihood depends on the
supply continuing to flow elizabeth
paranam al jazeera new delhi